yeah the question was if you're a
developer how do you find business
people to help you that's funny to me
because I think businesspeople suck [ __ ]
and are always swarming after developers
like you know like I think it's a lot
easier to find that I think I don't know
I feels like there's so many of those
kind of characters running around I
think the better question is once you
put yourself out there and get that how
do you filter and get rid of 90% of them
that are Street [ __ ] yeah that's a
good point
I thought I were you I just go out and
build it and launch it and then then try
and at that point if you start getting
gaining traction you'll have you'll be
swarmed by business people that want to
work with you I mean I also think the
whole like I'm just shocked you don't
big on the small town rules little
Jetsons Flintstones thing like honestly
I would ask the to 230 people that
you're the closest with and just start
that process
I'm surprised huh in this world we're
all friends and acquaintances I still
think we're something is important when
you go into business with somebody
you're marrying them it's a lot bigger
deal than I think people think
especially when you have success and so
I would really spend a lot of time
vetting who you want to go into you know
war with you know and so like for me
those questions go to my friends who I
really really trust not a tweet like who
wants a team up